right now in the United States one of
the world's largest volcanoes is gearing
up to explode it's known as the
Yellowstone volcano and it's not just
any regular volcano nope
it's a supervolcano if Yellowstone
decided to erupt the results would be
devastating but how bad would they be is
there anything we can do to stop it
would it affect the entire world and how
would this change our weather this is
what if and here's what would happen if
the Yellowstone volcano erupted tomorrow
located in Wyoming in the United States
Yellowstone has erupted three times in
the past two million years this has led
some people to wonder whether we should
be worried about another Yellowstone
eruption in the near future and by near
future we mean probably in another
couple hundred thousand years but
instead of waiting so long why don't we
find out what would happen if the
eruption took place tomorrow if you live
in North America there it would be
virtually nothing you could do to
prepare now that this supervolcano has
exploded well first what makes
Yellowstone a supervolcano anyway well
apart from it being larger in size a
supervolcano also produces a much more
massive explosion
most of the time when we think of a
volcanic eruption we think of the hot
molten lava spewing down covering the
surrounding area well while that would
happen at Yellowstone and it is
something you'd need to worry about it
wouldn't be the only thing in fact the
lava pouring out of the volcano might be
the least of your worries surprisingly
there wouldn't be much of it at least
not as much as you'd expect from a
supervolcano that's because before lava
leaves a volcano its first known as
magma but in this case a lot of
Yellowstone's magma won't be able to
become lava that's because it will be
shot up into the sky becoming airborne
ash particles and it won't just be any
type of ash these will be tiny scorching
little particles of jagged rock now this
would affect nearly the entire United
States and Canada tens of millions of
people within 1,000 kilometers of the
eruption would die if you breathe the
ash which would be inevitable in a
scenario like this it would form a
cement-like mixture in your lungs
causing you to suffocate buildings would
collapse as just 30 centimeters of ash
is enough to cave roofs in and you'd
still be in trouble even if you were
outside that 1000 kilometer range
experts say that even the east coast of
the United States would be covered with
1 centimeter of ash which would still be
incredibly dangerous to our human lungs
even parts of Europe would see some ash
maybe a light dusting and that wouldn't
be the only effect they've experienced
apart from the deadly ash everywhere the
entire world would experience a
temperature drop the ash lingering in
the air would block out the Sun
resulting in significant weather changes
the global temperature would drop by 10
degrees an effect which could last as
long as a decade the ash would also
affect crops water supply and virtually
everything else in the western part of
the world
so although you'd probably survive the
initial explosion you'd eventually
suffer the consequences of the ash
whether that means dying relatively
quickly or living long enough to
experience a colder harsher world
luckily you can take a deep breath of
ash less oxygen knowing that something
like this will probably never happen at
least not in our lifetime an eruption
like this at Yellowstone would be known
as a super volcanic eruption a more
likely explosion at Yellowstone would be
a hydrothermal eruption this mainly
involves a lot of steam and some rocks
hurtling through the air although
something like this would be bad it
wouldn't be nearly as scary as what
we're getting here a more likely
eruption at Yellowstone would be a
relatively simple lava flow in fact
since the last major explosion six
hundred thousand years ago we've had
nearly 50 of these eruptions and zero
casualties we know one way to almost
certainly get killed by lava and it
involves dropping your trash into it but
that's a story for another what-if